[Music]
obviously all of you
believe that your dad would be a great
president uh for this country
but
as people with families how do you feel
about your dad becoming president and
how that would change your life
we're nervous about it i mean it's uh
it's one of those things we our lives
are pretty good as they are and this is
one of those things where we recognize
it's good for the country for my dad to
run but not necessarily is good for us
and so we uh we're going to try and keep
our lives as normal and as as consistent
as they can possibly be over the next
few years
obviously
i believe you wanted him to run in the
last campaign were you guys reluctant
about him running this time we knew what
we're getting into this time and so
we're definitely more hesitant
i was really reluctant i didn't want him
to do it i tried to convince him not to
i think there were a few a few of us
that tried that i know you didn't but
i just felt like you know for for us as
a family this isn't the best thing but
as josh said for the country we think
it's the right thing
conan as you can probably tell i really
love the limelight so i was
i was
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Applause]